please welcome from La Rambla Hamburg
and Bill Pullman
I won't come
thank you so I've been watching this
speech again and again this week it's
like I think it's a great speech it's
very it's very presidential
well what do you say is the key to to
being presidential isn't is it the voice
this is the posture what what is it well
I don't you know for me I didn't groom
as a politician so when they were
talking about Independence Day I they
said you know they would like to invite
you to play the president United States
and I said is this a comedy I thought
it's got to be a comedy and then they
said no it's serious and I hadn't read
the script yet and I thought I
immediately flushed almost like
embarrassment you know like you were
talking about it because I thought I
don't but then I realized there's I
could figure out a way to do it and I
think the secret that I found was when I
was doing the costume
they had presidential cufflinks and
there was something about seeing the
little Eagles down there that was kind
of cool and I made me feel different
started from there you should have some
you know I think there was a difference
between being the President of the
United States and being Prime Minister
of Norway and or a Scandinavian country
I think our culture's are bit different
and I think speeches like the ones that
you gave here of course it's not up to
not all of us will would be in a
situation where you you're supposed to
save humanity in a way I mean we are
working on a little lower scale of yeah
I often that you know that you're facing
a lot though you know but the aliens are
would be a surprise is it you're doing a
sequel right yes to this film now this
spring yeah this summer kind of more May
June yeah are you still playing the same
part well the thing about presidents is
they have to go away for a while yeah
and I think that's part of the story the
this is you know nowadays with science
fiction movies they have to kind of keep
the story very quiet
I guess because they have Internet
people that can start crapping on it
right away and so they don't even tell
me so but I know that I'm you know it
was in the 90s that I was the president
and then the I actually kind of went far
astray and people began to think that
I'm you know maybe a little loose nuts
do you have that expression a little
crazy and but then I need to be called
back at a certain point because guess
what so is it is it true that that one
when the first one came out you got you
got to watch it actually with with Bill
Clinton that the president that that yes
yes that was a good surprise I have to
tell you and I did ride with you on the
plane today so I feel very special that
I got the ride on a plane with the Prime
Minister of Norway almost as good as
watching Independence Day thank you not
exactly Air Force One was it no yes I
was like commercial but it was yeah
quite a thrill to go to and it was last
minute they have a screening room in the
White House it's it's 52 people and
Clinton at President Clinton and Hillary
were down in front and we were standing
in the back we had just flown in with
helicopters from New York and last
minute it was like all the big surprise
that we were gonna get to go to the
Washington DC go to the White House
we're gonna watch the movie with the
president and we're standing in the back
and President Clinton stood up and
looked in the back you said somebody
one of you should be sitting here and
Dean Devlin was the producer who had did
quite a bit of the writing on and
everything he was like no he was a huge
fan of Bill Clinton he said I be too
nervous and then roland emmerich the
director said I'm German I can't go
so I it was ended up being me and I went
down there and and sat next to them both
as he watched me be the president
yeah what did they think well he didn't
say anything right away which kind of
made me feel bad watch a movie next to
somebody and it's over and they don't
turn that was great he didn't do that he
got up nice my 10th but Hillary turns
she's women you know there have a little
more consciousness but but he said if we
decide to go away for a weekend we know
who to get but I think he had something
here to check on and then he came back
and even then ways very this this this
fall you did you did a play on Broadway
with with the holy Hunter the actress
yes it was very much pressed and now you
you come here very very much I would say
off off off off Broadway which is Bergen
sorry about that I mean it's a it's a
very nice theater yes yeah in Bergen
you're doing oh hello yes this is a kind
of great adventure in my life because I
worked in the 80s with Stein Venga
Norwegian director in Los Angeles and
then he remains one of my favorite
directors I've ever worked with and last
year I had the idea that I want to work
with him again and so I came to see a
production in Oslo of the wild duck and
I also saw a Peer Gynt which was down in
Horton and and I the idea then was to
bring him to the States but he had
another idea the Pullman you should come
to Bergen and do a fellow and first I
thought this sounds like a joke from
Stein thing good Norwegian night the F
humor and what happened but then no he
was serious and I think this idea kind
of got loosened up because a little
hammer which is this interesting
phenomena with the you know Norwegians
and Americans telling this story and so
it's ending up being quite a fascinating
way to look at this play
do you do you speak there's some
Norwegian in it do you
yes I am just starting in on that part
of it but you know I don't I do have a
little these theatrical things that I
say in words from time to time I have a
you know a couple things that I I can't
afford but I say things like your multi
Draper for Oliva yeah I have to kill to
live yeah which is a line from
Shakespeare it's not me being
Independence Day yeah I think you did
that quite well can you say it again no
no okay
he died and there was there is a time
where it really had to be almost a black
African who played it to be politically
correct but that now this